[Music]
thank you
so Bobby Lee
went on impulsive
and well here you go no
so you're not gay
no
that's right that might be racist no
talk why no no because you said no I
just feel like everything
you know what I'm saying like that's
where we were that's you said it and
sexuality is incredibly fluid but I
hey what do you mean by that
yeah what's up how much of your fluid
have you you know exchange your day
Portnoy
do you guys go to the same gay
prostitute in Lexington Kentucky Devil
Boy Devil Boy
ah devil boy it's just whatever
I'm just I'm just you're the way you're
describing oh what was the other one
what was uh what was the one that
[ __ ] uh uh Ian came up with on Pie
Guys
[Music]
and sexuality is incredibly fluid but
I'm just I'm just you're the way you're
describing [ __ ] is so particular
thick sucking you know I I in my mind I
love how you look at me that happens I
love you I love you too
I want to go no no I want to can I
address one question at a time okay
I'm gonna say something
have I sucked penis ask me that question
that's what I should have said yeah
that's what I start over okay
Bobby Lee have you ever sucked it yes
let that sit
uh uncomfortable no not really okay good
how about you I hang out with these guys
I know hold on he's Christian you're a
little I don't know
whoa whoa that that that's [ __ ] up put
your hand back on his leg Bobby yeah
does that make you feel uncomfortable no
no oh it's so close
what is this I don't understand this La
podcast Community including Logan and
Jake Paul but Paul bro I don't get it
has North Korea figured out their
Rockets
he's licking his hand after touching his
penis
so it's generally understood I don't
know where your boundaries are I
apologize your PR team's [ __ ] in their
bags
I think they're okay
they gotta look like he got fired from
Apple bro
is this is this like what Zoomer comedy
is I'm not honestly don't understand
because none of these people are Zoomers
these people are about it I know they're
not Zoomers I'm saying the people that
watch impulsive resumers right we agree
I don't think so I don't know who
watches somebody has to watch Jake Paul
I don't think very young people are
watching Jake Paul I'm sorry Logan but I
meant to say Logan Paul
but they're like you're not a genius you
need to go yeah
he might be Bobby Lee wait which was the
one with the suicide forest
so that was this one Logan that's Logan
Paul did he have to have Bobby Leon like
the last time I saw him with an Asian
person was he was dead hanging from a
tree so it's kind of weird that he had
you know is this like pendants or
something well if kalila keeps her [ __ ]
up so will Bobby Jesus Christ let's
probably [ __ ] everybody in this room
except Bobby
including the Mohawk guy including
Mohawk guy yeah like you have the Genius
bar but they're like and the dog not a
genius you need to go he actually looks
like the only person that imbibilities
orbit that I actually like and I mean
this
is his producer yes producers his
producer for whatever reason I like the
guy he's funny oh he actually looks like
he might be Bobby Bobby I want to ask
about this because I have a father have
you sucked today uh not yet
not yet would you would you because
would you consider it he said not yet
it'd be tough I think my girl would
consider it cheating
so with stopping you hold on
what's the what's stopping you hold on
hold on so I'm gonna take remember True
Detective
membership detective yeah when we was
cutting up all the little men and he's
like well buddy if the only thing
stopping you from sucking a dick is your
girlfriend
then you're gay yeah that's a comfort
yes
I'm just ripping up a can and just
cutting it into little men with Boner
little dudes with bonus yeah
I know but if you were single in what
circumstance would you suck a piano I'm
so glad you asked this because I have an
answer yeah yeah oh my God
why do you have an answer and calm down
overacting idiot relax I love it I love
it I am so happy I love it it's been so
long I love it I love it
Logan Paul's about to suck his dick
[Music]
why'd you shake hands because
we have well you're [ __ ] shaking the
camera yeah
have you heard
of Dick Ransom guy
dick Rancic Ransom guy no I've never
heard of that tell me he's a guy who
goes around
and steals people
and that he finds their friends best
friends best friends yeah like he like
let's say he kidnap Mike for example
right and he said Logan
I'm gonna blow your friend's [ __ ]
brains out right now unless you suck my
dick unless you blow me you should have
gone there bro okay that's the only
circumstance That's my boy I'm sucking a
fat [ __ ] right
I'm sorry that you died I just want to
let you know Marshall no I'm sorry
you're dead Okay cool that's fair right
it seems fair right yeah
I would I would try to negotiate for you
because let me explain why you suck my
dick can I explain why is there an
amount of money I can just pay because
then what happens if
I do suck the guy's dick he kills us
both anyway and then I die a [ __ ] or
think about it this way you negotiate
with somebody like that then you're weak
everybody sees you as weak now you got
to suck everybody's dick I gotta save
you every week I'm sucking a new dick
it's like negotiating with terrorists
sometimes you got to let the hostage die
so they know you don't negotiate with
them and then just like Trevor Lawrence
you don't know if you were coming or
going
okay
why taper sorry you have to bleep out
that epsler was that a Jaguar's
reference huh Trevor no no no uh Trevor
the dude from not Trevor Lawrence God
damn Trevor Moore Trevor Moore makes way
more sense I don't know that's why I was
like I don't even like the Jaguars I was
like did he just call Trevor Lawrence
gay
would it surprise you he went in the
story
like if it was any of these guys in the
room you would suck everyone's penis if
it was this little guy right here would
you do him he'd have to Puerto Rico well
he's my videographer yeah yeah yeah I
would do it what about what about little
uh in a heart balls down the throat all
right
are we aren't we like Pat like past the
era where it's like funny to be like Oh
I'm talking to it I don't think they're
joking yeah they're probably just one I
think you just kind of want to talk
about sucking dicks
Mikey Mike 100 me
I wouldn't do it
it just blew his brains out dude why I
would come so quick
I kind of want to not watch this anymore
I don't want to be around I'm leaving
this one this is fun yeah just just pull
the parachute and jump what's up with me
what's up with that man
is that what those those shows are now